metro police say an off-duty officer
killed his daughter before turning the
gun on himself this happened early this
morning near lake mead and mlk jeremy j
ford joins us live near the scene with
the details jeremy
that's right sasha it actually happened
right here at corte madera town homes
and police ended up at around four
o'clock this morning getting a phone
call to dispatch but unfortunately all
they could hear
was
arguing you know the neighbors were
known to fight a little bit but i didn't
take anything too serious people fight
all the times but i guess this was
something serious early sunday morning a
domestic dispute involving an off-duty
north las vegas police officer turned
deadly swatton police were both called
to the scene we know that the wife and
the husband were both involved in a
argument
that argument turned physical when the
husband produced a firearm metro police
tell 8 news now the off-duty officer
shot at his wife but missed her and shot
his son in the hand
the mother and the son then fled from
the residence
to the nearby neighbor's house and the
female was stating that her husband was
currently inside the house and tried to
kill her the officer then fatally shot
his daughter before taking his own life
inside the residence unfortunately they
found the deceased body of the husband
and the deceased body of the daughter
it's scary it really is i mean the unit
that was involved they had a family
i just saw them the other day you know
but they were out barbecuing having a
great time so anything crazy like this i
guess can happen anywhere
now the two victims that were involved
in this incident are currently getting
treatment at a local hospital and police
want to remind the public that if you're
ever in a domestic violence situation
there's always help and you can find
help and resources on our website at
news at eight newsnow dot com live local
now jeremy j ford